en el centro de libro hay una imponente
sinagoga apoyada en el menor a centre un
complejo creado hace una decena de años
hay salas de conferencia a restaurantes
coser sucursales bancarias y agencias de
viajes un museo de la memoria judía y
del holocausto un complejo que se volvió
el corazón latiente del judaísmo en la
región en tiempos de guerra su sinagoga
se volvió evidentemente a un lugar de
acogida este hombre huyó de jarque
fuimos acogidos porque pertenecemos al
pueblo judío
tratamos de vivir aquí por el momento y
de reflexionar sobre nuestro futuro
vamos a irnos probablemente a nuestra
patria histórica y cerrada
muchas mujeres y niños se han ido desde
el inicio de la guerra menahem envió a
su esposa ya su hija a francia
80% de los que se quedaron son hombres
enviaron a su familia lejos de atelier
tuvimos aquí cada día para pasar tiempo
y ayudarnos porque en nuestras casas
están vacías
en falsas
los hombres que se quedaron rezan
asiduamente igor tiene 90 años ya ha
conocido la guerra y el exilio
es la segunda guerra que vivo a mi edad
y no tengo ganas de irme pero creo que
ucrania va a ganar así haya muchas
víctimas y destrucción
y
vamos a reconstruir y el señor público
logrará obtener lo que quiere de
la comunidad judía en ucrania está
estimada en algunas decenas de miles de
personas pero serían unos 400 mil
individuos según el congreso judío
europeo una comunidad que sigue siendo
una de las más importantes de europa
entonces ironiza mos cuando evocamos el
discurso ruso según el cual vladimir
putin lanzó una guerra total contra los
nazis ucranianos soy el jefe nazi soy yo
el principal nazi que digan lo que
quieran ya no tienen nada que decir es
por ello que hablan de nazis de
fascistas y ucrania siempre ha sido la
cuna de la vida judía siempre lo ha sido
nunca ha habido nazis aquí
a seis horas por carretera de mi libro
hacia el oeste de umán esta pequeña
ciudad acoge la tumba del rabino najmán
de breslov atrae a decenas de miles de
judíos jasídicos durante una
peregrinación anual la guerra no le
impidió a martín hacer el viaje vino
desde nueva york pasando por turquía y
luego moldavia
aquí está enterrado el rabino najmán de
breslov que se fue hace más de 200 años
somos sus discípulos es nuestra
inspiración y vamos a visitar su tumba
para orar y aprender
el barrio judío en el que la comunidad
posee numerosos hoteles y comercios está
casi desierto muchos habitantes se
fueron a israel
puede ser algo que tras el inicio de la
guerra esta sinagoga fue abierta para
los desplazados y a todos como refugio
la edificación acoge a una de las más
grandes sinagogas de europa en cinco
niveles
las relaciones entre los cifran ya no si
los jasídicos
se volvieron más cercanas que antes los
jasídicos suministraron hoteles
gratuitamente para acoger a los
ucranianos que llegaban y buscaban
salvar su vida ament destino de tu ser
lives
adele hace parte de los que se quedaron
ella tenía como proyecto abrir una
pequeña tienda de comestibles en el
subsuelo de este edificio la guerra hizo
lo suyo ahora prepara comida para los
desplazados que huyen del este del país
preparo casi todo yo misma en cada plato
hay una particularidad ponemos nuestra
alma hay gente que viene y baja los ojos
porque siente vergüenza de pedir ayuda
esta situación puso a todo el mundo en
igualdad de condiciones sin importar la
nacionalidad o la religión
adele dudo mucho antes de quedarse en
umán había preparado sus maletas para ir
a alemania o israel antes de echarse
para atrás
tenemos la tierra santa de israel
pero es nuestro deber estar aquí ahora
la guerra provocó el exilio de una parte
de la comunidad judía pero confirmó una
tendencia que existe desde la revolución
de maidán en el 2014
la pertenencia a la religión judía no es
de ninguna forma un freno a una forma de
patriotismo ucraniano y muchos de los
que se fueron esperan regresar
[Música]